every country has an obligation to
protect its borders and its citizens
particularly one is expansive and as
generous as the United States now for
too long immigration law was ignored
frankly and basically unenforced Obama
tried to kind of enforce it in an ad hoc
fashion but it's policies which are
going to get to in a moment only ended
up exacerbating our problems at the
border so today we have a full-on crisis
a hundred and sixty percent increase in
the number of people illegally entering
the United States from just last year
well the president is responding with a
zero tolerance message which he
reiterated today the United States will
not be a migrant camp and it will not be
a refugee holding facility won't be you
look at what's happening in Europe you
look at what's happening in other places
we can't allow that to happen to the
United States not on my watch now the
president is now doing what we should
have been doing all along prosecuting
all border crashers so if you enter the
country illegally you're breaking the
law the United States is not an open
repatriation center where any indigent
person in the world feels free to just
walk in and assume that all of us will
take care of all of them and their
families there's a process and it has to
be respected homeland security chief
Kirsten Nielsen said this today we are a
compassionate country that has taken in
millions of refugees since 1975 the
United States has welcomed more than
three million refugees from all over the
world and each year typically admits
nearly two-thirds of the world's settled
refugees that is more than all
other countries combined we will not
apologize for the job we do or for the
job law enforcement does for Duke for
doing the job that the American people
expect us to do illegal actions have and
must have consequences no more free
passes
no more get-out-of-jail-free cards well
consistent with American law when a
party is arrested your children are
either sent to relatives or they become
Ward's of the state
so since more illegal immigrants are
rushing the border more kids are being
separated from their parents and
temporarily housed and what are
essentially summer camp camps or is the
San Diego union-tribune described them
today is looking like basically boarding
schools having lost the argument and
frankly the last election liberals have
seized on the separated children and
turned the entire image into a political
weapon attempting to emotionally
manipulate the public perception of
immigration enforcement I've read that
you have said that the separation in
your words you said is nothing less than
government sanctioned child abuse do you
really think that this amounts to child
abuse this does amount to child abuse
and all I can say after talking to the
people watching the people listening to
the people that the Statue of Liberty I
think is weeping right now effectively
orphaned thousands of children from
their parents I'm heartbroken by what's
happening and I wonder what this means
about the fabric of our country now why
are all their hearts breaking in unison
now why no tears for the victims of
illegal immigrant crime like the
fourteen-year-old girl raped by
Anastasio Eugenio Lopez Fabian just last
month or did their heart break when
another fourteen-year-old was left to
die at the scene of a hit and run by
Miguel Ibarra serde a 21 year old
Mexican national my friends here's what
you're not hearing the government has
very good reasons for separating these
children from their family unit the
first being they may not be the chant
child's family at all children have been
kidnapped trafficked and used by
individuals
who can then more easily slip into the
country the Obama administration's catch
and release policy allowed people with
children to enter the United States with
only a promise to show up for a later
hearing a lot of them didn't show up of
course the human traffickers and the
drug cartels quickly seized on the
weakness and Exploited it routinely
trafficking people across the border
using children at times as camouflage
then when Obama announced his daca
policy in 2012 it became yet another
lure for illegal immigrants the number
of unaccompanied minors from El Salvador
Guatemala and Honduras surged between
2012 and 2014 check this out by more
than four hundred percent the number of
unaccompanied children referred to the
Office of refugee resettlement tripled
between 2012 and 2017 from thirteen
thousand six hundred and twenty five to
forty thousand eight hundred in ten
according to the government statistics
from these immigrants come fresh
recruits for ms-13 and other gangs that
terrorize American cities from Maryland
to California we've talked to the
officials who told us the stories and in
June of 2014 even the Washington Post
had to admit that the unaccompanied
minor surge was quote driven in large
part by the perception that they will be
allowed to stay under the Obama
administration's immigration policies
astoundingly in the fiscal year 2014 the
Border Patrol apprehended 68 thousand
four hundred and forty five quote family
units few of course were deported now
you throw in sanctuary cities a lacs
amnesty program and it's a wonder more
illegals haven't come so the Trump
administration is now trying to pick up
the pieces of this lawless immigration
system after decades of governmental
neglect they're also trying to
responsibly protect children in the
government's care here are the
circumstances under which they
temporarily take Kentucky study of
children number one when
HS is unable to verify the relationship
between the adult and the child number
two when DHS determines that a child may
be at risk with the parent or the legal
guardian and three when the parent or
legal guardian is referred for criminal
prosecution now you enter into a normal
port of entry rather than coming across
the border illegally and the chances are
you're not going to be separated from
your families but most of these people
are coming straight across the border as
illegal immigrants then claiming some
type of status or asylum request and
this all goes back to a 1997 court
ruling we've talked about before on the
show called the Flores settlement which
forbade the government from holding
unaccompanied children for more than 20
days ditto for those traveling with
family units so unless you have a
hearing within 20 days they have to be
released into the country okay unless
you'd be swayed by the media reports
that the children are housed in
concentration camps or cages the truth
is the US taxpayer is spending a lot on
the care of these children nearly
$35,000 per year per child they actually
have a higher standard of living than
the 13 million American children today
currently living below the poverty line
it's about 24,000 per household and as
for the conditions of the facilities
that the immigrant children are housed
in they live a lot better than some
inner-city kids or say the 11,000 472
homeless veterans living here in
California anything we've seen the
government has provided this doesn't
feel like we're in the United States
Department of Health and Human Services
invite us inside because I think they
wanted to show us you know relatively
speaking how good the conditions are I
guess you could say I mean there are
licensed professionals in there that are
taking care of the children there are
not cages there are not fences it's just
ridiculous I mean the bottom line is
these kids should be united with their
parents for sure reunited with their
parents back in their home countries
they should not be burdens to the United
States taxpayer or
thrown into a system of foster care by
parents who think coming across the
border with children will just assure
them eventual legalized status the
president wants the separation to end as
well
president Trump has said this
lawlessness cannot continue we do not
want to separate parents from their
children you can be sure of that
if we build a wall we pass some
legislation we close some loopholes we
won't face these terrible choices and
rather than trying to score political
points
Democrats and Republicans like sessions
as indicating should come together they
should do what's best for the country
for the American citizen and the
American workers and these immigrant
children the law should be changed so
that the Border Patrol
can turn away individuals and family
units at the border if necessary today
only Mexicans who cross the border
illegally can be turned back that's
absurd
our Border Patrol doesn't exist as a
wave in facilitator for any group of
supposed family members who mouthed the
script given to them by lawyers
non-governmental institutions or other
people in their home countries that they
mouthed for asylum the American people
are footing a really big bill for what
it's tantamount to a slow-rolling
invasion of the United States and we can
no longer permit Central American
countries to export their poverty and
their desperation to our nation our own
children black white Asian and Latino
need help to in Detroit here in LA in
Hartford in Miami and in Chicago so why
don't the bushes and the Obamas and all
these left-wing reporters emoting today
at the White House and all these Pro
amnesty Democrats and Republicans why
don't they ever write op-eds or cry for
those kids you know why because they
think this over-the-top coverage and a
misrepresentation of what's going on
will hurt the man that they could not
beat in November 2016 Donald Trump and
that's the angle